et qu'est-ce qui se passe lorsqu'on
ouvre l'enveloppe on se dit ça y est je
vais la voir et puis quand le nom ne
sort pas il y a une déception comment
est-ce qu'on vit là non il y avait pas
de déception
entendu des bruits de couloir et cetera
et puis que
et puis que non mais en fin de compte je
suis très heureuse de pas l'avoir eu
c'est vraiment bizarre sur le moment
j'étais un peu gêné parce que je me suis
dit c'est quand même c'est quand même
dur de le donner à celles qui a le plus
gros seins quoi parce que c'était
vraiment ça en plus ça sentait c'était
tellement évident et non mais c'était
ignoble moi j'ai trouvé ça assez mais en
fin de compte je me suis dit bah tant
mieux parce que comme ça au moins ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que je suis
pas je suis pas un produit qu'on essaie
de monter en épingle comme ça en deux
trois mois parce que c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour elle et que je suis je suis
en fait je suis plus une comédienne
qu'une savonnette donc je suis très
fière qu'est-ce qu'il a déjà eu la fille
aux gros seins c'est qui
je me rappelle plus moi j'ai oublié les
Césars déjà quoi